Game ändern, ich muss noch Game ändern, what the fuck, On-Stream-Titel ändern, so, so
Leute, ich werde jetzt mit dem Fabian noch ein bisschen bobsgrinden in BDO und das war's
dann, so, ich muss aber erstmal zum Vault mein Zeug abgeben, wo ist der Vault, da oben
irgendwo, ist hier der Vault, äh, wo ist denn der Vault, Storage, wo ist der Storage,
ach, da ist da unten der Storage-Dude, äh, hier ist der Storage-Dude, ne, wo ist der
Storage-Typ, äh, what the fuck, moin Leute, Lautstärke okay so, ich muss meinem Bot mal
sagen, er soll nicht mehr spammen, hä, wo ist, angeblich ist hier ein Storage-Typ, aber
wo ist der Storage-Typ, ist das dumm, ne, ich komme jetzt, ich komme jetzt zu euch,
klar, ich bin da, ich finde bloß den Storage-Keeper nicht, ich bin zu doof, ja, ich habe das
oben über die Hilfe, aber irgendwie da, wo der hinläuft, steht nichts, was Storage-Dude
ist, äh, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo der Storage-Dude ist, ich komme jetzt erstmal zu euch, ja,
äh, Leute, ich rede gerade mit dem Fabian, also mit dem Frazier, ihr hört ihn aber nicht,
weil das ist auf einem anderen, auf einem anderen Rechner an, die wollen ihre Ruhe,
äh, ja, das ist Absicht, dass man nichts hört.
Eigentlich wollen wir hier nur ein bisschen sinnlos Mobs grinden, sonst nix, wo ist denn
der Karsten, ja, da oben ist er, da unten ist er, ich habe nichts Großartiges mehr
heute vorne, ich, ich levele jetzt, fuck, ich levele jetzt noch ein bisschen im Kreis
und das war's, dann gehe ich pennen, ich bin nämlich so übertrieben vollgefressen,
Leute, das könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen.
Ich habe jetzt bestimmt einen Monat einmal richtig gespielt, aber Wizard, Wizard muss
man eh nix können, Wizard reicht nur, wenn man einfach drei verschiedene Knöpfe drückt
und gut ist.
Ja, das ist das neue Gebiet, das gibt es seit dieser Woche, ja, so Wald, Waldstelz, ich
kenne meine Spells nicht mal mehr, wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht mal mehr, wie meine Spells
sind, gescheiter.
Ah, ne, ich habe ja noch so eine AE, stimmt, ich habe so eine AE.
Feuer-AE auf dem Boden, der übelst Damage macht und dann habe ich noch, ich habe noch
Rechtsklick, der übelst Damage macht und Linksklick, der übelst Damage macht und Knockdown,
der übelst Damage macht, eigentlich macht er alles übelst Damage von Wizard, aber irgendwie
habe ich sonst mehr Spells verwendet, was habe ich denn vergessen?
Ah, ich habe erstmal, habe ich hier meine Mana-Kugel vergessen?
Ich kann nicht, es ist unmöglich.
Ey, man kann Wizard eigentlich nicht nicht spielen können, das geht nicht, das ist so
der typische, so der typische Drei-Button-Char, aber ich habe meine Spells vergessen, seitdem
ich da mal gespielt habe.
Schade, dass Puppke nicht so hübsch ist, ja, das wäre cool, oder?
Wenn die Map da so aussehen würde hier im Video.
Wizard kann jeder spielen, ne.
Warte mal, was muss ich denn hier nehmen noch?
Das ist doch überhaupt nicht das richtige Food, oder?
Was ich hier habe.
Was ist denn der Karsten da?
Au.
Warum machen das so viel Damage?
Was war nochmal hier?
Oh, oh.
Das war hier.
Guck mal hier, was der für Damage macht.
Ich habe irgendwie auch noch so ein Damage-Absorb gehabt und ich weiß nicht mehr wo.
Schlimm.
Ah, hier brauche ich mal ein Absorb.
Stimmt, Absorb.
Hier, wo ist er?
Da, Absorb.
Ich erinnere mich wieder an die Spells, so langsam.
Ja, optisch eher ist das Spiel wirklich sehr hübsch.
Alter, das sieht wirklich gut aus.
Kann man nichts sagen.
Ist das ein Boss, oder was?
Ähm, wo rennt denn der Karsten schon wieder hin?
Der Karsten rennt immer so verplant rum, da weißt du überhaupt nicht, wie du hier herlaufen sollst, ne?
So, was muss ich denn jetzt für ein Food fressen?
Uptime.
Uptime ist halt 5 Minuten oder so, nicht lang.
Ich levele jetzt noch ein paar Runden, dann gehe ich pennen.
Irgendwie stimmt auch meine Food-Leiste nicht.
Muss ich mir gleich nochmal in Ruhe angucken.
Bäm, Ulti.
Schreckt.
Fragt mich, wo der Fabian rumrennt, der wollte ja, der müsste ja jetzt auch irgendwo sein.
Ich glaube, der PvP-t irgendwo wieder vor sich hin.
Boah, bin ich voll gefressen.
Ey, mir tut aber auch weh.
So, Buff-Food.
Was brauche ich denn jetzt hier?
Das Inf ist voll mit irgendeinem Scheiß.
Oh, welches Buff-Food davon habe ich denn jetzt gebraucht?
Das hier?
Valencia-Meal?
Habe ich Valencia-Meal gebraucht?
Was ist die richtige Buff-Food-Rotation?
Ich habe es zu lange nicht mehr gespielt.
Au.
Ich glaube, Valencia-Food, ne?
Valencia-Food bringt Evasion.
Also, ich muss auf jeden Fall...
Ich muss auf jeden Fall...
Ich muss auf jeden Fall jetzt nochmal...
Das bringt Casting-Speed, Attack-Speed, was?
Attack-Speed, gut, dann muss ich das da fressen.
Ah, nice.
Jetzt haben wir jetzt schon mal ein paar ordentliche Buffs.
Casting-Speed plus 10% läuft aus und...
Das ist dann doch Valencia-Meal, hä?
Nö.
Wobei, das passt, das ist XP-Trank.
Rotation ist dann XP-Trank.
Selendia-Meal, Media-Meal, ja genau, das passt.
Das ist ordentliche.
Ich muss jetzt mal die Pet beschwören.
So langsam aber sicher checke ich auch wieder halbwegs, was ich hier mache.
Ja, Hans-Karl, du kannst es oben rechts in deinem Profil ausstellen.
Du kannst einen Haken wegmachen von Beta.
Dann startet Twitch nicht mehr in der Beta.
Übrigens, hört man überhaupt was vom Sound?
Hört ihr irgendwas vom Gamesound?
Das ist ganz schön leise.
Ich höre nämlich selbst kaum was.
Jetzt müsste es Gamesound geben.
Echt, der Haken kommt immer wieder und das Problem habe ich nicht.
Hast du Cookies?
Löschst du irgendwie Cookies, kann das sein?
Gibt ja Leute, die haben so Addons installiert, die die Cookies löschen und sowas.
Dann kann sich die Seite natürlich nicht merken.
Wenn der Twitch-TV tut nicht, wenn man auf Twitch Beta ist zur Zeit, ScaryLeggy, das geht nicht.
Dann musst du Beta ausschalten.
Das ist noch verbuggt auf Beta.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass wird die nächsten Tage dann funktionieren.
Hoffe ich.
Weil ich will auch die Beta-Seite von Twitch verwenden.
Obwohl ich gar nicht so gut weiß, wie es funktioniert.
Obwohl ich gar nicht weiß, was der großartige Unterschied ist.
Wisst ihr, was der Unterschied ist zwischen normalem Twitch und Beta-Twitch, was die da verbessert haben?
Was ist da jetzt anders?
Bisschen Overlay.
Okay.
Was, Zugang zu neuen Streams?
Wie ist, wie darf ich das verstehen?
Was meinst du mit Zugang zu neuen Streams?
Ach, dass mehr vorgeschlagen wird.
Okay.
Ich baue meine richtigen Items an.
Ich glaube schon.
Oh, bin ich vollgefressen.
Oh, ist das ein Boss?
So aus.
Carsten, du kriegst Damage.
Gebashed.
Griffin, gebashed.
Was hast du heute gemacht, dass du so voll bist?
Ich war Asia-Buffet.
Sonntagsbuffet.
Also nein, nicht Sonntags.
Wochenend-Buffet, all you can eat-essen.
Die hatten da irgendwie 6, 7 verschiedene Stationen.
Einmal so ein Typ, der dir was gegrillt hat.
Ein anderer Typ, der dir...
Konntest dir selbst Zeug zusammenstellen.
Der eine hat es auf den Grill geschmissen.
Auf so eine heiße Platte.
Der andere hat es in den Wok geschmissen mit Soße dabei.
Da hatten sie noch so einen offenen Grill, wo sie Spieße drüber gemacht haben.
Plus noch irgendwie ein paar andere Stationen.
Eine Sushi-Station.
Irgendwie alles mögliche.
Ich hab, keine Ahnung, 8 Teller oder so gefressen.
Also nicht komplett vollgeladene Teller.
Aber 8 Stück.
Ich bin mit euch im Arsch.
Carsten, hör zu, sag doch.
Carsten, du hast es leider schon verpasst, als ich über dich gelästert habe.
Leider zu spät.
Ich hab gesagt, der Carsten rennt immer so planlos rum.
Da kann ich gar nicht hinterher rennen.
Das ist so zickzack halt.
Ich hoffe, dass sie auf Lanzarote in Spanien auch einen guten Asiamann haben.
Also ich glaube, Lanzarote ist jetzt nicht unbedingt bekannt für gutes Asia-All-You-Can-Eat.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es das da nicht gibt oder so.
Ich glaube, der Fokus liegt auf was anderem.
Warum mache ich da eigentlich nicht mal ein E-Dot-Feld rein?
Das wäre sonst zu Easy-Mode als Wizard einfach.
Der Bot nervt mich.
Sebaro, kannst du irgendwie die Spam-Benachrichtigungen zum Battlefield-Server ausschalten?
Kannst du das Remote machen?
Mit einem Kommando?
Oder muss ich...
Wenn das nicht geht, mache ich schnell die Bot-Nachrichtigung.
Das ist halt schwierig hier mitten in den Mobs.
Zumindest nervt der Bot mit dem Battlefield-Server-Spam.
Kommst nicht?
Vorhin, ne?
War auf meinem Battlefield-Server noch was los?
Also quasi...
Auch wenn ich nicht mehr drauf war, was mega geil ist.
Vielleicht ist der Server ja ab und zu mal bevölkert.
Auch wenn ich nicht da bin.
Wäre nice, dann könnte man nämlich einfach mal so ein bisschen drauf spielen.
Gibt eh zu viel...
wenig gute Battlefield 3 sauber mit gescheitem Regelset. Oh, was macht der hier? Au, krass, was ist das hier? Da gehe ich nicht rein. Ich will wieder kein XP verlieren. Wenn du das sagst. Die machen da richtig Damage, die Möpse, ey. Krasse Möpse. Richtig Damage. Da muss jetzt mal der Master Chief kommen und so.
Wo ist der Master Chief, wenn man ihn braucht? Cortana habe ich schon, war mir auf dem Rechner. Wo ist der Master Chief? Ja, das ist Call of Duty Beta, was ich hier spiele. Das Neue. Call of Duty Fantasy Warfare 2.
Oh, da ist er down. Der Mob. Da geht er down. Was habe ich hier noch für Kack? Loot. Alles weg. Gibt eh kein Geld.
Thousand Loot, lol. Thousand Loot in 2K17. Oh, bin ich voll gefressen, ey. Ich könnte mal einen Damage Buff machen. Oh, das ist nicht mein Damage Buff. Das ist mein Damage Buff. Das war mal übelst Damage in der Zeit.
Guckt euch das mal an. Das ist gereckt. Die Federwölfe. So ein typischer MMO Mob Name. So ein typischer MMO Mob Name.
Wo ihnen sonst wieder nichts einfällt. Federwölfe. Was ist mit denen los? Warum hat ein Wolf Federn? Oh, ne, hier geht es nicht lang.
Der hängt da am Stein. Der geile Wizard. Und der Mob Sound ist auch wieder mal absolut High Quality.
Uuuuh, uuuuh. Ah, das ist ein Low Budget Game. Also das ist jetzt keine Letzt BDO, das übelste Low Budget Game.
Und auch ein ziemlich kleines Team.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie es mittlerweile ist. Das merkt man dem Gamer auch an vielen Stellen an.
Ja, Karsten, stimmt. Hast recht.
Nur ein paar Webpanel.
Oh, ja, dann ist es... Ach, komm.
Dann spammt mein Bot halt alle 10 Minuten. Wir werden es überleben.
Wizard Gameplay ist echt spannend, oder? Was sagt ihr?
High Octane Gameplay.
Karsten, ich heile mal ne Runde.
Das Viech lebt ja immer noch.
Das kleine Witzchen.
Der Mob Sound.
Was ist... Was war mit den Leuten da von... von Dings von...
Kakao... Ne, nicht Kakao Games. Ähm...
Fuck, wie hieß der Hersteller nochmal?
Pearl?
Pearl irgendwas? Was war mit denen kaputt?
Haben die aus irgendeiner Sound-Datenbank genau einen Wolf-Sound rausgeholt, oder was?
Die hat nur einen Wolf-Sound. Mehr gab's nicht.
Kaufe drei Mob-Sounds. Bekomme einen for free.
Ähm... Eax war... Äh... Was war Elex nochmal? Das... Das Gothic?
War das das Gothic? In der Zukunft?
Ich bin grad... ein wenig verwirrt.
Es... Es hört sich zwar so an, als wäre ich besoffen oder so, aber das stimmt nicht. Ich bin bloß vollgefressen.
Und so halb im Koma.
Ah, das neue Gothic. Ah, da bin ich auch mal gespannt drauf.
Ich war schon immer eher für Gothic, als für... für Elder-Scrolls-Games.
Die Elder-Scrolls-Formel ist nicht so meins.
Schlimmste war Elder-Scrolls Online.
Failgame.
Carsten, ist immer noch ein deutsches Studio?
Keine Ahnung, wo die mittlerweile sitzen.
Könnte aber sein.
Hallo, D-Striker.
Sebaru, du musst Asia All You Can Eat machen.
Ja, aber das macht nix, das Stream-Delay ist... äh...
Das... das...
Ja, aber das... das Stream-Delay ist nicht... nicht lang, nur 10 Sekunden oder so. Das geht schon, Carsten.
Das ist einfach ein bisschen... ein bisschen wie Brain-Lag.
Kochst du eigentlich auch manchmal selbst oder gehst du im Infest?
Manchmal koch ich auch was.
Aber... es hält sich in Grenzen.
Ich hab eigentlich selten Bock, was zu kochen.
Meine Mutter kocht mir manchmal was.
Was dann ganz nah ist.
Aber meistens hol ich mir was.
Hol ich mir entweder was zu essen, Lieferdienst.
Oder abends zu mach ich mir mal irgendwie sowas...
Oh, fuck.
Steh auf, Wizard.
Nicht rum... stolpern hier.
Abends zu mach ich mir mal irgendwie Spaghetti Bolognese oder so.
Also nicht, dass ich nicht auch ein bisschen was Komplizierteres zustande bekomme, das geht schon.
Aber ich hab da meistens keinen Bock drauf.
Da springt er mit seinem Ranger-Grill rum.
Der Frasier.
Mammutl!
Hat er nicht gehört.
Ein was für... Moment, wie heißt dieser Mob?
Ein... ein was? Ich erkenne es nicht. Ein Belladonna Elephant.
Weiß nicht, was mit den Japanern da kaputt ist bei den Mob-Namen.
Ein Belladonna Elephant und ein Federvolf.
Oh stimmt, Carsten, du hast recht. Sind Koreaner, keine Japaner.
Hab ich ganz... stimmt, hab ich verwechselt.
Das ist ja ein koreanisches Game.
Guck mal, da sind Gegner, wollen die uns bashen?
Was wollen die Typen von uns?
Ah, der Fabian schreibt schon, der macht das.
Der Fabian sagt, das pisst euch alle.
Oh, ich muss ja über den Chat was drüberblenden, fällt mir gerade auf.
Fabian flamet die Leute, so muss das sein.
Gleich mal Revier markieren hier.
Es gibt Flamer, ist mir doch egal.
Frasier ist der beste Flamer, den es gibt.
Ich kenne... ich kenne keinen, der die Leute so gut flamen kann, wie der Fabian.
Oder was heißt flamen?
Man nennt es ja neuerdings nicht mehr flamen, sondern disrespecten.
Das ist besser. Man flamt heute nicht mehr, heute wird disrespected.
Au.
Kackmob.
Wo ist der Carsten? Soll ich den Mob jetzt alleine bashen, oder was?
Mein Wizard sagt, ich kann das definitiv nicht alleine bashen.
Wegkocken ist immer noch das beste Wort, kenn ich... ja.
Wegkocken, ich finde... wobei, ich finde wegkocken ist...
Also, wegflanken finde ich auch nicht schlecht.
Oh, jetzt habe ich ja...
Ähm, Carsten, kannst du mal kurz alle Mobs bashen gleich?
Ich muss nochmal Chat-Overlay reinmachen.
Mal Chat, Chat-Overlay...
Ähm...
Passt, passt, ich habe es schon, ich habe es schon.
Bei flanken muss ich immer an Inscop21 denken, wieso sagt der das auch?
Das passt zum Nico.
Das ist meine Katze, ja, Carsten.
Oh, das passt.
Wegflanken.
Das kann ich mir so richtig vorstellen.
Ich kann mir das richtig vorstellen beim Nico.
Ja, der Nico, da hat er wieder weggeflankt.
Das kann ich mir richtig vorstellen, so.
Ich kann...
Wie?
Was sagt der immer?
Der hat doch auch so... der hat doch auch so ein...
So ein Spruch, ähm...
Ich gucke das zu selten.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ah, fuck.
Was hat...
Was hat der da nochmal für ein Spruch?
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ja, habe ich gesagt.
Stimmt, das war das.
Ja, jetzt ist es wieder eingefallen.
Eigentlich auch richtig bescheuert.
Aber irgendwie lustig.
Ich mag den Nico.
Der Nico ist der einzige Lifestyle-Channel.
Das ist so der...
Der originale Lifestyle-Channel irgendwie.
Auch wenn ich es nicht gucke.
Das ist der...
Er macht das nicht.
Der hat das nicht gemacht auf seinem Channel, weil er irgendwie der Ansicht ist,
das ist jetzt krasser Lifestyle, das machen alle, das gibt krasse Views, sonst was.
Nee, der ist einfach so.
Außerdem ist er nicht so ein Spast wie die anderen Lifestyle-Typen.
Fashion.
Ich checke hier übrigens null, was abgeht, ne.
Ich charge einfach sinnlos auf irgendwelche Mob-Packs vor mir drauf.
So.
Fashion, Alter.
Moment, Fabian, hast du auch den Streamern?
Okay.
Naja, wolltest du, weil du hast gerade in diesem Moment bashen gesagt, wo ich auch gesagt habe, bashen.
Das Game ruckelt? Warum ruckelt das Game?
Fuck.
Was ist hier los? Ich habe einen 1080 Ti, da darf bei Definition nichts ruckeln.
Das ist unruckelbar.
Du hast recht, Karsten, das stimmt schon.
Aber ich bin gerade nicht mehr so richtig zurechnungsfähig.
Das ist unruckelbar mit einer 1080 Ti und warum ruckelt das?
Korea Optimization, lol.
Ich habe 27 FPS? Das gibt's doch nicht.
Liegt bestimmt noch daran, dass ich vorher Call of Duty gestartet habe auf dem gleichen Rechner.
Es reicht, wenn es einmal auf dem Rechner gelaufen ist, dann ist Instant Rip.
Dann läuft kein Game mehr.
Ich meine, ich sollte ja keine 25 FPS haben.
29 FPS.
Sollte ja schon ein bisschen mehr haben.
Was mache ich denn da?
Hahaha, ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Ich meine, das Game sieht schon wirklich hübsch aus, muss man sagen.
Danke für die Follower, ich sehe es gerade leider nicht, wer das gewesen ist.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich es gleich in der Vorschau sehe.
3-Wood-AK-47.
Einfach nur ein Mob-Sound für alles.
Ah, stimmt, ja.
Ich habe es gerade wieder vergessen, dass man ja eh nach 24 FPS nichts mehr sieht.
Ja, das ist ja richtig.
Eigentlich kann mir das gar nicht auffallen, dass es ruckelt gerade.
Das geht gar nicht.
Das ist nicht möglich.
Außerdem habe ich gerade ein Auge zu, dann sehe ich eh nur noch 12.
Stimmt so, oder?
Ich habe es richtig gerechnet.
Ist das die richtige Rechnung?
Also 24 FPS durch zwei Augen, das heißt 12.
Sogar der Carsten gibt mir recht.
Der Carsten kennt sich mit sowas aus.
Kennt sich besser aus, als ihr alle im Chat hier.
Das sind Noobs da.
Ah, Carsten sagt gerade, das hat auch was damit zu tun,
dass er das Auge zumacht.
Das wusste ich noch nicht.
Das ist mir jetzt neu gewesen.
Ich dachte, solange man das Auge nicht ganz zu hat, zählt es voll.
Wenn man es zu hat, zählt es nur noch die halben FPS.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt quasi das Auge nur zur Hälfte zumache,
dann habe ich quasi weder 24 noch 12, dann habe ich so 18 oder sowas.
Stimmt das, ja?
Ja, okay.
Nee.
Oh, endlich habe ich es mal verstanden.
Noobsbast.
Oh Leute, das ist ein Witz.
Wie es wieder einige nicht checken, ey.
Manchmal muss man das wirklich auch immer so alles direkt aufs Brot schwimmen.
Carsten gleich Kaboom?
Nee, Carsten gleich Mastercrapper.
Der einzig wahre Mastercrapper.
Der Kaboom heißt Thorsten und ich Carsten.
Aber fast.
Ja, Happy Fill.
Das kann jetzt jeder behaupten, dass er es verstanden hat.
Das kann jetzt jeder behaupten.
Aber ich glaube ja, dass wir wollen ja mal nicht so sein.
Ey, ich bin so im Fresskoma.
Ui, jetzt habe ich 22 FPS.
Yeah.
Carsten, wie viel FPS hast du hier?
Sag mal, das würde mich interessieren.
50?
Du hast 50 FPS?
Moment.
Sind meine Settings im Arsch oder was?
Okay.
Carsten ist ein imaginärer Freund, genau.
So.
Ey, warum hat der Carsten mehr FPS als ich?
Das geht doch gar nicht.
Aber das dürfte es eigentlich gar nicht ausmachen, großartig.
Dafür habe ich eine Grafikkarte, die ist 30 mal besser.
Wusste gar nicht, dass du streamst.
Doch.
Heute habe ich saumäßig viel gestreamt.
Ich habe heute Vormittag gestreamt.
Also bis 15.30 Uhr.
Und jetzt nochmal.
Aber jetzt eigentlich auch nur, weil ich noch nicht pennen kann.
Weil mir der Bauch weh tut von zu viel Asiol.
Ich meine, an OBS kann das ja auch nicht liegen.
Das ist Ruckel.
Ich mache nämlich Grafikkarten-Encoding.
Das sollte überhaupt keinen Einfluss haben.
Bei dir geht nur noch die Beta-Seite.
Äh, Marvin, kannst du nicht oben rechts auf dein Profil klicken und den Haken wegmachen bei Beta?
Das müsste eigentlich gehen.
Lass mal die Mammutels bashen hier.
Nee, nee, passt schon.
Dann lädt die Seite nicht komplett.
Okay.
Ja, ich lasse den Stream über TPU entkoren.
Also OBS sollte bei mir wirklich kaum TPU-Last verursachen.
Also keine Ahnung, warum ich hier nur 25 FPS habe gerade.
Aber gut, das ist BDO.
BDO, das ruckelt halt immer.
Ich glaube, das kann gar nicht flüssig laufen, das Game.
Das ist halt highly optimized.
18 FPS.
Das kann aber echt nicht sein, langsam.
Wo sind die Settings hier?
Ich meine, viele habe ich schon an.
Max, hast du einen Tipp?
Ich will mir zu Hause einen kleinen Saubercluster aufbauen.
Ich finde einfach keine günstigen Sauberschränke.
Äh, ja, habe ich.
Guck mal bei Musik-Equipment.
Oder was willst du?
Was willst du?
Wie groß?
Was brauchst du denn?
19 Zoll?
Mit welcher Tiefe?
Oder nicht 19 Zoll?
Was willst du haben?
Ich muss jetzt mal in Taskmanager gucken, was hier so viel...
Oh, die Tails.
Ja.
BDO-Verbrauch, CPU-Leistung.
Sonst fast nichts.
Nur BDO-Verbrauch, CPU-Leistung.
Aber ich könnte auch einfach mal diesen komischen Slider hier anmachen.
Dass Effekte verringert werden.
Bei FPS.
Fuck, ey, wie viele Mobs.
Äh, Cheese-Nudel, ich habe heute kein MW2 mehr, äh, äh, World War 2 mehr gespielt heute Abend.
Erst nur heute Morgen.
Wo ist denn dieser komische Slider?
Wo ist denn der Quality-Slider?
60.
Bäm.
Äh, wirklich, was bringt uns das jetzt nicht?
Schaltet der quasi alle Effekte aus?
Was wirklich bringt uns das nicht?
Ich mach jetzt die, ich mach jetzt die Quality mal ein bisschen runter.
Quality low.
So, jetzt darf das Game noch laden.
Das wäre auch nice.
Ja, äh, Funky-Doh, sag mal, was du, was brauchst du denn?
Also, was willst du für eine Grö...
Boah, das Spiel sieht das scheiße aus, ey.
Wie, wie tief soll er sein?
Wie hoch soll er sein?
19 Zoll, rund 80 Zentimeter tief.
Um die 20er, eh, okay, 80 Zentimeter, das ist schon volle...
Fast volle Tiefe.
Also, na, da passt es.
Da passt alles rein.
Fast alles.
Okay, dass ich jetzt die Qualität runtergestellt habe, bringt auch nichts, außer dass das Spiel noch viel beschissener aussieht.
Ähm.
Guck mal bei Audioschränken.
Guck bei Audio-Racks.
Ich mein, mein ich ernst jetzt.
Guck mal bei Audio-Racks.
Oh.
Mein Game sagt, es ist korrupt und muss neu gestartet werden.
Habt ihr gehört?
Äh.
Hallo?
Mein Game ist korrupt und muss neu gestartet werden.
Ähm.
Vielleicht hat es deswegen auch so geruckelt.
Vielleicht hat es deswegen auch so geruckelt, der Scheiß.
So.
Nee.
Auf geht's.
Audio-Rack.
Ja, guck mal bei Thomann zum Beispiel.
Bei Thomann kannst du mal gucken, was es da für Audio-Equipment für Racks gibt.
Da gibt es auch welche mit Rollen und sowas.
Die sind halt für Auto-Equipment gedacht.
Die sind aber auch 19 Zoll und haben die Löcher an den richtigen Stellen für Schrauben und so.
Ah.
Game ist immer noch korrupt.
Fuck.
Ich glaube, ich kann auch nicht mehr spielen.
Mein Game sagt jetzt beim Laden, dass es korrupt ist.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal Scan machen.
Das dauert jetzt ewig.
Ich hab ne SSD und das backt einfach rum.
Das ist BDO.
Das ist...
Ich glaube nicht, dass meine SSD kaputt geht.
So, GLHF, BDO.
Ja, Eax, ne?
Bei mir kackt alles ab.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was da los ist.
Aber wenn meine SSD wirklich Defekte hätte, dann hätte ich andere Probleme.
Außerdem kackt ja sonst nichts ab.
BDO hat es schon öfters mal gehabt.
Und...
Äh, Cod.
Ist einfach kaputt.
Ich glaube, ich geh jetzt pennen, klar.
Was ist das?
Ich hab schon mal nach Epic Music gesucht auf YouTube.
Das klang nicht so epic.
Nee, ich lass die Überprüfung jetzt laufen und dann ist gut.
Ohohohoho.
Ich find das ultra entspannend, die Halo-Menü-Musik.
Ich bin kein Halo-Fanboy, aber ich spiel das kaum.
Aber ich find die Menü-Musik ist so entspannend.
Ja.
Fucking Clown, das geht weiter mit dem Windows-Update.
Mit dem nächsten Windows-Update.
Machen wir das Programm weiter.
Ähm, ich hab mir nämlich überlegt...
Wir machen das als Windows-App.
Als Universal-Windows-App.
Und mit dem neuen Windows-Update wird das viel einfacher und besser.
Deswegen warten wir da drauf.
Das kommt ja schon im Oktober.
Also kommt ja ins... in...
14 Tagen.
Du findest auch bei Audio-Racks nicht...
Moment, ich guck jetzt mal...
Funky Dough...
Ich guck jetzt mal, was bei Thomann...
Wird mir bei Racks...
Das, das guck...
Das kommen wir...
Das gucken wir jetzt mal zusammen.
Okay?
Wir gucken das mal.
Wir suchen jetzt mal für den...
Wir suchen jetzt mal für den Funky Dough...
Suchen wir jetzt mal einen...
Billiges Rack raus, wo er seinen Server reinstellen kann.
Ja.
Und wir gucken absichtlich nicht nach Server-Racks, sondern nach...
Studio Audio Racks.
Weil das...
Billiger ist.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Easy.
De... De... De... De... De...
Die Halo-Musik ist so geil.
So.
Ich zoome mal ein bisschen ran, weil die Seite wieder...
So, das ist die Hälfte, ist.
So, gucken wir doch mal hier.
Wo steht das denn hier, Rack
Divinity 2
Wenn ich dazu komme
Wo haben die denn die Racks nochmal stehen
Wo stehen dann die Racks nochmal
Ja Karsten, wir spielen das zusammen
Wir spielen das zusammen
Das ist ein geiles Game
Guck mal hier, was ist denn das
Thomann
Ihr 19 Zoll Racks
Da ist doch das, da sieht man, da hat man doch hier Zeug
Guck mal hier mal, 20er E19 Zoll Racks
Okay, das ist
Die sind alle ein bisschen kurz
Aber die sind hinten offen, also
Wenn es dir nichts ausmacht, dass deine Geräte
Ein bisschen überstehen
Wobei ein 80 cm Surfer würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
Ein 50 cm tiefes Rack stecken
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen unbalanced
Dann am Ende
Ah, die Racks gehen aber wirklich alle nicht so tief
Na gut, Audio Racks
Haben halt selten
Bedarf auf 80 cm Tiefe
Dann können wir noch
Guck mal, in dem Shop
Hab ich mein Rack gekauft
Wie hieß das denn
Rack Magic
Da hab ich mein Rack bestellt, weil es die einzigen waren
Die kleine
Mit kurzer Einbautiefe hatten
Aber vielleicht haben die ja auch größere
Guck, die haben 44 mm Tiefe
Ja, das ist doch was für dich hier, oder
Das ist doch was für dich hier
Funky Dough
Sowas hier in der Richtung
Hier
12, was ist hier
Tiefe 80 mm
Höhe 21 He
Farbe schwarz
Da kannst du, musst du noch einen Deckel dazu kaufen
Und hier neben so eine
So eine Verbindung
Sonst ist es zu wackelig
Und dann ist es doch ganz schick
Wenn du jetzt natürlich einen Schrank haben willst
Dann sieht es wieder anders aus
Schränke musst du mal gucken
Da fällt mir so aus dem Stehgreif nichts ein
So, was macht ein BDO so
BDO überprüft das Game
Was meinst du Carsten
Das ist nicht Halo, ne
Alter BDO, werd mal fertig
Das ist doch so ein Team
Das ist doch kein Team
Klar, ich bin ein Team
Ja, Marvin, es geht bei mir
E-Mode Auto Complete
Oh, ich bin im Arsch, ey
Hübsch!
Remains of the Despossessed
Return with bombs strapped to their chest
Nee, Sofa Troll, nee, nee, das täuscht, das täuscht, von außen schicken.
Und in Quantum, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab, kommt zum ersten Mal Teile, die in Rust
programmiert sind, in Firefox rein.
Und zwar eine CSS Engine, die parallel, also auf mehreren CPU-Kernen CSS parsen kann und
Seiten stylen kann.
Das ist schon gut, was sie machen bei Mozilla.
Einziges Problem, was ich sehe mit dem neuen Firefox ist, sie haben ja mit dem letzten
Firefox Release, haben sie ja die alten Addons deprecated, also haben gesagt, hier, demnächst
gehen die Dinger nicht mehr.
Addons, die die alte Addon-Schnittstelle verwendet haben.
Und mit dem neuen Firefox werfen sie sie jetzt endgültig raus, also sie gehen dann gar nicht
mehr.
Vorher gab es nur eine Warnung, jetzt gehen sie gar nicht mehr.
Und das ist schon doof, weil es noch viele Leute gibt, die ältere Firefox-Addons verwenden.
Die halt nicht mehr funktionieren noch, suckt ein bisschen.
So, ich brauch jetzt mal Epic, Epic-Musik-Playlist, Leute.
Gebt mir mal Epic, Epic-Musik-Playlist, ich brauch jetzt eine.
Gibt's denn hier sowas?
Ja.
Most, MOST EPIC, MOST EPIC MUSIC, MOST EPIC, nicht einfach nur Epic rein, es ist MOST EPIC.
Okay, machen wir das mal an, MOST EPIC, wöh, aber noch ist das nicht MOST EPIC, fuck, Anele-Musik,
so Epic ist das jetzt nicht.
Du kannst links posten, ja.
Ich spul mal ein bisschen vor, ob's MOST, puh, nee, das gefällt mir hier grad nicht.
Davon bist du überzeugt, okay, ich mach's mal auf.
Ich mach's jetzt mal an.
Boah, da denkt man wundern, was für krasse Mobs man hier basht mit der Musik.
Ah, das hier.
Almost design.
Hauptsache dick Streicher aufgetragen.
Wenn nix geht, Streicher.
Das geht immer.
Ich glaub, das ist ein bisschen laut jetzt, ne?
Tickenleiser.
Ey, mein Bot geht mir auf den Sack.
Nein, Bot, halt die Fresse.
Lull.
Nein, Bot, you baited.
Oh je.
Geht's ab.
Es ist grad Endboss hier.
Es ist grad Endboss.
Zumindest kommt das bei der Musik so vor.
Ich seh grad Endboss.
Härtester Worfboss im ganzen Game.
Endboss der Worfboss im ganzen Game.
Goodbye Leute.
Nicht hittenlassen.
Bashen.
Bashen, gleich ist er down.
Jawoll, WorlDfrst.
Clear.
Zumindest hört sich das laut der Musik so an.
Wie 10s.
Moment, das kenne ich.
Aber es hört sich halt auch einfach viel, wie dieser Soundtrack, naja, das heißt so,
sind kein Soundtrack. Da gibt es eine eigene Musikrichtung,
diese Trailer-Musik da. Hört sich vieles
relativ ähnlich an.
Also oftmals denkt man, hey,
das kenne ich und dabei kennt man das gar nicht.
Das kenne ich
nämlich gar nicht. Hat sich so eingehalten wie was anderes.
Dann auch
den obligatorischen Fake, äh,
den Fake Latein-Chor.
Deswegen kann man
sich auch an dieser Ultra-Epic-Musik
schnell satt hören.
Weil das hört
vieles verdammt
ähnlich an, ja.
So, man nehme einfach
30 Milliarden
Streichinstrumente, dann
typt der ab und zu mal auf die Trommelhaut
und ein Fake Latein-Chor.
Doch,
das kenne ich.
Das ist nicht Heart of Courage,
das ist irgendwas Courage, äh,
nee, äh, das ist,
das ist Heart of Courage? Nee.
Aber hört sich ähnlich an.
Ah, hier, Two Steps
from Hell, genau.
Das hört sich alles so an.
Nicht, dass es schlecht ist, aber es hört sich einfach alles so an.
Kann, kann jetzt mal dieses
scheiß Overlay hier weggehen?
Hallo, Overlay,
verpiss dich mal.
Ich hab Half-Life durchgespielt, mittlerweile
evolieren. Ich warte jetzt noch, dass die Xen-Levels
rauskommen. Gibt's da was Neues?
Ja, gibt's was Neues zu Xen-Levels?
Ja, wisst ihr das?
Weiß das jemand?
Irgendwo klingelt ein Telefon. Ah, nee, das ist
ein Discord.
Wir müssen jetzt noch mal kurz...
was anderes anmachen.
Okay.
Ja, Carsten,
das passt, dann geh ich auch...
Ich geh dann auch pennen.
Wenn du...
Wenn da Carsten...
Wenn da Carsten dann
AFK muss, dann...
Ja, Sentinel of Cod hab ich.
Oh, ich hab hier gar keine Storage.
Nur Eviton-Store.
Zahl die Kollektion. Ich hol mir das
Para her damit. Komm schon, wenn
nicht mit Rap, dann mit der Pumpgun.
Oh, schon
fertig.
Aha, Para ist Geld. Okay.
Wobei, Half-Life ist jetzt nicht
Para, das ist dann wenn schon Para oder so.
Para. So, was könnte
ich jetzt hier noch mal für ne Musik
schön zum Ausklang spielen?
Was könnte
man? Oh!
Was zeigt
mir denn hier?
Oh ne, jetzt hätte ich mal besser nicht angucken
sollen. Ich hab grad gesehen,
dass es Gameplay zum neuen
Secret of Mana Remake gibt.
Und das
bestärkt ja schon meine ganzen Befürchtungen
zu dem Remake.
Was könnte ich denn?
Time to say goodbye.
Das ist eigentlich
sehr
gutes Outro. Ich hab ja schon ein Outro.
Hab ich schon ein extrem
Outro.
So.
So Leute, ich geh jetzt schlafen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.